as we enter into the 1900s Imperial
Russia is under the absolute control of
the Czar and a czar an analogous term
would be emperor he has absolute control
over Russia and he's part of the Romanov
dynasty Romanov dynasty that has had
control that has ruled over Imperial
Russia since the early 1600s so for
roughly 300 years but as we see from the
late 1800s through through the early
1900's really over the course of tsar
nicholas ii rule you see ever increasing
tensions between the ruling class
between the royalty and the aristocracy
and the labor class sometimes called
referring themselves as the proletariat
the proletariat comes from an enrollment
society it was the the lowest class the
people who were kind of doing the labor
in Roman society but they proudly
referred to themselves as a proletariat
and as we'll see the the revolution that
occurs in 1917 that's really the
culmination of the struggle between the
laborers the ones that are working under
ever increasingly harsh conditions in
factories in urban centers or the ones
that are working in the fields and and
the ruling class and this tension just
keeps getting worse and worse and worse
as we get into 1905 and 1905 is one of
the more notable events that show that
things aren't going all that well for
the Tsar in January of that year you
have a an Orthodox priest leading a a
strike leading a protest trying to get
this is in st. Petersburg trying to
march to the Tsar's palace and it's an
unarmed it's a peaceful protest but they
want to be heard they want to explain to
the Tsar how hard the working conditions
are for laborers under in in Imperial
Russia and the Tsar isn't actually in
town at the time but his force is
actually opened fire on these peaceful
protesters and that that that event in
which there's all these casualties of
these peaceful protesters is called
Bloody Sunday bloody and this was in
January Bloody Sunday which is in
January of 1905 and this sparks an
attempted revolution where
are it people who are sympathetic to
those protesters they start taking to
the street throughout Russia you start
having the government forces suppressing
them wherever they are but eventually
that that revolution is put down it's an
unsuccessful revolution but it increases
the tension even further and frankly
even folks who might have been somewhat
sympathetic to the Tsar before almost
viewed him as a bit of a father figure
now are thinking hey you know this guy's
forces open open open fire on peaceful
protesters maybe he's really not on our
side and those tensions continue to
increase as we go all the way into 1914
which we've seen in other videos is the
start of World War one and like happens
and we've seen it in both World War one
and World War two Russia tends to take
the brunt of these things and World War
one is incredibly difficult on Russia
first of all all of the a good fraction
of the young men have to go fight then a
lot of the economy has to be repointed
at supporting the war effort at the
supplies for the troops the food for the
troops and so it starts to really hurt
the conditions for the average person
which were already bad remember they
were protesting in 1905 and now things
are getting worse as we go through World
War one for the average individual now
to make a bit of a concession to the
general public and to move somewhat into
a more representative world after the
Revolution of 1905 the Tsar does create
the Duma which is a representative
assembly representative assembly that
didn't have a ton of power but it did
start to give the people voice and every
time they assembled to him whether the
Tsar was actually not too pleased with
it he's like who are all of these people
who seem to be very aggressively anti me
and he kept getting the Duma dissolved
and then a new Duma would be elected and
this kept going on and on and on all the
way until we get to the beginning of
World War Ron now as I said World War
one conditions start to get worse people
start to get even more skeptical of Tsar
rule to make things even worse when tsar
nicholas ii has left st. petersburg to
really help lead the troops or in his
mind lead the troops near the front of
the war the country or the empire is
really goes under the control of his
wife the czarina Alexandra and she is
heavily under the influence of this
gentle
right over here Gregory Rasputin and
Rasputin is one of these fascinating
characters from history because he was
this mystical faith healer type guy who
was able to really manipulate the the
czarina and to some degree the Tsar and
so people started getting suspicious of
well who is this guy this mysterious guy
who's hanging out in the palace and
seeming to have very strong influence
over our rulers and there were even
suspicious of the czarina at this time
the lot of the royalty they married
between countries and the czarina she
was actually born in Germany and her
father was German she grew up in Germany
and her mug Rand mother was actually
Queen Victoria of England and you might
remember that that Russia is now at war
with Germany so they're like hey we have
this German czarina essentially
controlling the country under the the
sway of this mysterious shady figure
Gregory Rasputin people do not like the
way that this is going and so by 1917
things come to a head and in February
and especially March of 1917 the they
are able to force the Tsar to abdicate
to say hey enough is enough
we're taking it straight to you you have
to you have to give up your power and
it's called the February revolution but
the Tsar doesn't actually abdicate until
March so you could argue that you could
call it the March revolution
now once the Tsar abdicates you have a
provisional government you have a
provisional government take control and
all of this is happening in 1917 but
people are also not happy with this
provisional government remember the war
is continuing to go on it's not really
looking that well for Russia they're
continuing to lose people the economy is
continuing to tank and what you have is
workers start to to start to assemble
start to organize in the various cities
and they form these workers councils
these councils and the word and Russian
for them is Soviets these Soviets start
to form and you fast forward into
October of that year and these Soviets
are able to along with the Bolsheviks
which is a party are able to force the
provisional government
to to abdicate its power or to give up
its power and then you have the control
by a Soviet council and in the Soviet
Council
the Bolsheviks led by Vladimir Lenin are
the ones who are actually able to take
power now revolutions I mentioned you
know what revolutions are happen or
they're the culmination of decades of
increasing tension and as we've seen
multiple times in history revolutions
are not clean things it's not like the
Tsar abdicate or the government
abdicates and another government takes
over and then everyone's all nice the
Bolshevik Revolution which installs
which it now has this Council of Soviets
which we're the Bolsheviks aren't
control led by Vladimir Lenin you can
imagine the people who are royal who are
loyal to the king the monarchists
they're not happy you can imagine people
who are more aligned with capitalist
models of government because the Soviets
and the the Bolsheviks they are strongly
strongly socialist they they're
followers of Marx they imagine an ideal
state that has a that has very limited
private property rights and on and on
and on and so this sparks a the Russian
civil war which lasts from 1917 to 1922
and like most civil wars it is
incredibly bloody you have two to three
million casualties two to three million
casualties as part of that civil war and
casualties those could be deaths those
could be injuries but in the end the
Bolshevik Red Army is victorious and
sometimes that civil war is viewed as a
conflict between the Red Army of the
Bolsheviks the one that favoured
socialism extreme socialism communism
really and the white army the army that
was either on the side of the
monarchists or they're more capitalist
but they're definitely against the red
army and there's also another group the
green army which is you know not aligned
with either one of them so let me let me
write this down it's really the Civil
War is Red Army versus versus white army
versus white army and then there's even
the notion of a green army which is not
aligned with either of these verses the
green army and this continues all the
way through 1922 until the Red Army is
able to be victorious and that's really
the official
of the Soviet Union in 1922 and Lenin is
the first premier of the Soviet Union so
he is the premier of the Soviet Union
but he does not last long he eventually
dies from from natural causes a few
years later in 1924 where he is followed
by Stalin and you might be asking well
what happened to the Tsar and his family
after they abdicated well it's not that
great of an outcome and it's it's at
least for them and it's one of these
famous things in history where his
entire family his entire family actually
gets executed the summer after he
abdicates and so this was an entire
family every member of his family was
was executed there were some theories
that that one of that his daughter right
over here Anastasia might have actually
escaped but it was later Lee later
conclusively proven that she too was was
also executed so you see that right over
here the Tsar abdicating in nineteen
abdicating in 1917 and then the next
summer
his entire family is actually executed
so it's a bloody beginning
it's a bloody period but this this is
kind of what happens when you have
significant revolutions